when we think of gods in Greek mythology
we think of these chiseled aesthetically
pleasing figures and the same can be
said for the goddesses they always
seemed to have this air of beauty and
desire witness about them but when we
think of the God her feast us Beauty is
one of the last things that comes to
mind and the circumstances surrounding
his birth they're a bit strange to say
the least
her feast us is considered to be the
child of Zeus and the goddess Hera but
in some stories Hera was jealous that
Zeus had given birth to Athena without
her assistance seeking revenge Hera then
gave birth to her feast as' without the
aid of Zeus because of this solo birth
her thesis was not like the other gods
and goddesses of the Greek pantheon they
were known for their beauty and her
thesis was born ugly and deformed
had he been a mortal man then this
wouldn't be an issue but as her thesis
was a God
his mother Hera was ashamed of what she
had created she rejected her child
throwing him off Mount Olympus despite
the long and dangerous fall her thesis
eventually landed in the sea near the
island of Lemnos he would eventually be
rescued by a sea goddess named fetus who
took him to the island of Lemnos where
he grew up never really known where he
was from in the stories were her faeces
had a more conventional birth it wasn't
until he was older that he was thrown
off Mount Olympus by Zeus when he
attempted to protect his mother from
Zeus's rage the fall from Mount Olympus
did not kill her feast as' but instead
he was crippled by the fall causing the
limp that her feast as was often
depicted as heaven
growing up on the island of Lemnos her
feast this was raised by the local
thracian tribe where they taught him to
become a great craftsman he would
eventually construct his first ever
forge on the island where he began
making trinkets and jewellery naturally
as he grew older he became more curious
as to the identity of his parents and
when he had found out of his origins and
what had happened to him he began to
plot his revenge her thesis his skills
with his Forge became so renowned that
word even traveled to Mount Olympus and
he crafted a great golden throne that
will be transported to the gods as a
gift when his mother Hera sat upon the
throne she became engulfed by the throne
and she was unable to move with Hera's
powers being valued so highly this did
cause some concern amongst the gods her
thesis was summoned several times to
Mount Olympus by Zeus to release his
mother but he remained on the island of
Lemnos ignoring all communication with
his father
it was the god Dionysus that would
eventually bring her fee system aunt
Olympus but this wasn't by choice or
persuasion Dionysus succeeded and making
her thesis extremely intoxicated and
bringing him to Mount Olympus on the
back of a mule when her feasts are
sobered up zeus essentially bribed him
if he released his mother then he would
be given a prominent role on Mount
Olympus from then on a thesis would be
regarded as the god of the forge scoped
in metalwork fire and volcanoes he would
also now be seen as the blacksmith of
the gods where he would craft all their
weapons and accessories he crafted many
things at the requests of the other gods
but one of the faeces his most worn own
creations was that of the first female
human Pandora which he created at the
behest of Zeus
hephæstus also provided zeus of a
solution to his problem regarding the
goddess Aphrodite who was considered the
most desirable of all the goddesses and
Olympus Zeus was facing a possible war
between gods for her hand in marriage as
part of their agreement
Zeus promised Aphrodite to her feast as'
who accepted in disbelief that a goddess
as beautiful Aphrodite would ever be his
wife needless to say the prospect of
being married to her feast us was not
one that appealed to Aphrodite and it
wasn't long before her affections were
focused elsewhere
Aphrodite soon took a liking to the God
of War Ares
but their relationship did not go
unnoticed the Titan of the Sun Helios
witnessed to several times he then
informed two feasts of his wife's
actions her feast is now infuriated by
the actions of his wife began creating a
contraption that would catch her in
Aries in the act the next time the two
lovers would meet they triggered the
trap that was set by her feast as' mid
lovemaking and they were ensnared by an
unbreakable golden net her feast
distract both Aphrodite and Ares back to
the other gods assuming that they would
be punished but instead the other gods
were more amused in the way that
Aphrodite and Ares had been caught by
her feast as' the two lovers were
eventually released unpunished and not
long after Aphrodite felt pregnant with
the goddess Harmonia the father was
indeed Ares and Aphrodite and her feast
as soon went their separate ways but
like many divorces
it wasn't exactly a civil process a
feast has exacted some revenge on ephra
deity when he crafted a cursed necklace
the necklace of Harmonia which brought
pain and suffering to all those who
possess the necklace
her thesis in Aphrodite born Oh children
but it said the God was believed to have
many more two lovers one located near
each of his numerous forges this led to
her feast as having several children of
notes including King Alenia s-- our
duelists the inventor and palimony as'
one of the Argonauts but perhaps his
most well known son was Eric o Gnaeus
the man who would one day become the
king of Athens the circumstances
surrounding his birth are also quite
strange her feast has attempted to court
the goddess Athena but when she rejected
his advances he tried to force himself
upon the goddess in the process he
ejaculated on her thigh Athena brushed
the semen away but when the semen fell
onto the earth Gaia she became pregnant
and born from the earth was Eriko Gnaeus
the future king of Athens it's believed
that her feasts as his main Forge was
located in Mount Olympus with his
secondary Forge back on Lemnos these
subsequent forges were built beneath
each one of the ancient world's
volcanoes volcanic activity was often
explained as her feasts at work this
does someone explain him being referred
to as Vulcan in Roman mythology her
thesis is prize creation was undoubtedly
his automatons they allowed living
objects and creations to be brought to
life he used them to even make his own
hand maidens even the furniture in the
palaces of Mount Olympus was able to
pack itself away because of the
automatons of Hephaestus her feast us
was one of the most creative gods in
Greek mythology creating nearly
everything you associated with the
Olympians from the helmet and sandals of
Hermes to the arrows of Artemis and
arrows he also had a hand and build in
many of the great palaces of the mortal
kings he was closely linked to the story
of Prometheus when he stole fire from
Mount Olympus to give to man the fire
was taken from the forge of her feast
as' the thesis then took part in the
punishment of man and Prometheus when he
crafted Pandora and bound Prometheus to
the caucus mountains of Chains he had
forged
before looking into her feast us in any
detail I always considered him to be a
minor deity what caught me by surprise
was how many stories that he was
involved in and how reliant the other
gods were on her feast us anything that
the gods needed was crafted by her feast
as' and so many of the iconic weapons
and trinkets used by gods and Greek
heroes were made by the god of the forge
her thesis is story has everything you
could want and expect hardship tragedy
lust and revenge if there's one thing
we've learned today it's don't anger
Hephaestus because he will exact revenge
he's a resourceful and extremely clever
god but like most great creators he can
also be eccentric at times I hope you
guys enjoyed learning about her feast
as' if you're anything like me then your
opinion about the god has definitely
changed if you guys enjoyed the video
then let me know what you thought in the
comments below but as always I've been
your host mythology and fiction
explained
[Music]
[Music]